more than 130 dogs are now cleared from
the canine pneumovirus sometimes these
things happen in shelters just because
of the environment we're a public
shelter so we're kind of like the public
hospital after one of the fostering and
adopting events in late September the
shelter found out about a dog that
tested positive for pneumovirus and
strep Zoo it later had to be put down
putting limits on operations for more
than a month but CEO Hillary gray says
they had protocols in place which played
a big role in tackling this as well as
advice from National experts because of
the way that we manage our kennels in
our rooms and the shelter we were able
to detect right away which dogs had been
exposed to that dog you know who had
been in rooms together while on
antibiotics the dogs were isolated from
red yellow and green rooms to determine
where they were in their recovery the
foundation kept updating the public
through social media posts noting none
of the dogs had to be put down but
during our interview it was revealed one
dog had to be put down the dogs were all
responding very well and none of the
dogs had to be put down does that
statement still stand true today well
there was the initial dud that was
euthanized off site who had some other
complications and then there was one
other dog that had health complications
that Dr Miller can talk to you about a
little bit more partially from the virus
but also some other health issues the
other one that you just mentioned this
is the first I'm hearing about it have
you guys considered making that
information public
yeah I mean um we we're talking more of
transparent about it and talking to you
about it today Chief veterinarian Casey
Miller explains more on the dog was put
down he had extensive behavioral
concerns and was just not doing well
um here in the shelter and I'm coupled
with a couple of our other medical
issues she says the dog's medical issues
could have been treated and he was
responding well to the antibiotics when
you talk about behavior issues with this
dog can you describe what they were yeah
so this dog was noted to be just very
shut down not wanting to interact with
other people
not wanting to eat his food that sounds
like a depressed dog though not an
aggressive dog CEO gray explains why a
dog would be euthanized we'd never want
to be euthanizing for space there are
instances of grave illness where it's a
mercy as you know a lot of owners go
through that towards the end of their
animal's life too or if you have a
dangerous situation a bite a vicious
animal that kind of a thing